let's let's let's talk about what uh
what dr fauci is doing here with the
story we've had from tim cast the story
actually went up earlier this month
a couple weeks ago
exclusive fouchy's nia id funding island
of monkeys in south carolina used for
horrific maximum pain experiments it's a
report by cassandra fairbanks with
sourcing from white coat waste project
dr anthony fauci and the national
institutes of health are using an island
off the coast of south carolina to breed
monkeys for use in horrific maximum pain
animal experimentation and i must state
i hate doing this
but i had to remove the images from the
article because i can't show them on
youtube because they're graphic
but this is what fauci's niad is funding
and i have to wonder why it is so do you
want to break down for us what this this
primate island stuff is what is fauci
doing sure so this is it's called morgan
island it's off the coast of south
carolina there's in fiscal year 20 there
was 3 521 monkeys on this island and
each year they take about five or six
hundred of them
into fauci's labs fauci owns the monkeys
fauci's division owns these three
thousand five hundred now hold on is
this fouchy
like
as an individual pointing the finger and
saying i want these monkeys moved or is
it like him signing off on a grant and
then throwing into a pile
um
it's unclear we have foia requests in to
see what his degree of knowledge is
about this directly but it's been in the
news a lot over the years the fact that
this place exists
um he probably knows about it it's a big
program of theirs it's where they get
most of their monkeys yeah signing off
on the grants to run the stuff as the
director yeah that's right so it'll be
interesting to find out to what degree
of his involvement is but yeah carry on
tell me what's going on um so they take
about five or six hundred of these
monkeys off the island each year bring
them to the labs in bethesda and
maryland
and then they expose them to infectious
diseases
including covid
uh including hiv aids including nepa
virus loss so lots of lots of illnesses
that no one in the united states has
ever gotten
um and then that sounds really dangerous
it's dangerous and it's also is that how
the nih should be spending our money on
you know when there's plenty of
neglected diseases that are hurting
people i mean our position is that the
taxpayers should not be funding any of
this all at all and the private sector
should fund it if it's so important yeah
um
so these experiments involve you know
creating diseases that are causing
monkeys pain hemorrhaging multi-organ
failure
brain damage and then they completely
withhold any pain relief
because they don't want it to interfere
with their experiment that's looking at
how these diseases progress so some of
these experiments are just to see what
happens when you create a monkey model
of these horrible infectious diseases
and then so that's we call them maximum
pain experiments because they're
classified as causing significant pain
and distress and then intentionally
withholding the pain relief and just
watching these monkeys slowly die or
quickly die depending on why why so
they're doing it because they're like we
want to know what happens with this
disease we want to see how
it reminds me of uh i don't want to you
know equate humans and animals to to a
great degree i certainly think primates
as you know higher intelligence species
there's degrees to which we're willing
to tolerate torture of animals and
experimentation but it does remind me um
well i'll i'll start here for first i
was just saying how elites treat us like
chicken like cattle like like you know
just fodder and we had what was it unit
uh unit 731 741 yeah 741 do you know the
japanese
experimental unit world war ii they
would take their like one one example is
they took a person and they stuck their
hand in like sub-zero temperatures so it
would freeze and they shattered it to
see what would happen
and then you had the nazi scientists
they were basically i wonder what'll
happen if i do this to a person now
interestingly they say that we a lot of
a lot of the stuff we know about
frostbite comes from these inhumane
human experiment experiments
and i'm like
you know at a certain point my attitude
towards freezing to death and losing
limbs is kind of like we know you'll
lose your limb and you'll freeze to
death if you uh are exposed and how
about we reckon we just have to
reconcile the fact that our knowledge of
hypothermia must come through uh
emergency accidents like if you want to
learn about frostbite it's going to be
due to the fact that someone got lost in
the cold and you're bringing them into
the hospital to save them and watching
what's happening not subjecting them
these experiments in this case maybe pro
maybe scientific progress shouldn't be
sped up by the fact that we're taking
primates that we bring on an island to
basically torture just to see what
happens and the point is is it's not
sped up by doing this right so our name
you know white coat refers to the
experimenters and their white lab coats
and then waste is a reference to the
fact that the nih on its own website
admits that nine out of ten drugs that
pass animal tests fail in human beings
because they don't work or they're
dangerous so we have 20 billion dollars
a year spent on animal experimentation
we know that it's failing 90 to 95 to
alzheimer's for example alzheimer's
drugs over 99 failure rate
so it's an incredible waste of money
there's there's very little return on
investment for taxpayers which is why we
think that if this stuff is so important
let the gates foundation fund it but we
know that
there are not private foundations that
are going to fund a lot of this stuff
because it's completely wasteful it's
irrelevant and it's not going to help
anybody what is it just lining people's
pockets with gold oh yeah it's big money
i mean universities are taking
25 off the top just for administrative
fees
and then you've got experimenters
driving nice cars and living in gated
communities and it's big business you've
got the companies that make the cages
that breed the animals that you know
there's a company that runs monkey
island and they have a 13 and a half
million dollar contract so we went and
saw ghostbusters after life
thought it was fantastic great movie and
then um the next day i was like let's
watch the original ghostbusters the
original ghostbusters is about three
university professors who are up doing
paranormal research operating off a
grant and then the dean comes in and
says we're shutting down your grant and
all of a sudden they're like what do we
do there's a scene where dan aykroyd is
talking to bill murray and he says you
don't know what it's like in the private
sector out there they demand results in
here you get grant money you sit around
and do nothing
and i i i reminded of that because
that's it yeah there are people who are
probably sitting there and their their
their field of research is you know um
nerves and like pain and stuff like that
and they're like
i don't know what to research
let's just get a bunch of badgers and
beat them or something i don't know and
then they get a grant and then they get
hundreds of thousands of dollars to the
grant the university gets their cut they
get paid a six-figure salary they get to
drive their nice car in their gated
community and just like hey we hit a
gopher with a hammer and it died that's
what we learned
i mean i'm obviously exaggerating but
you're not not far you're not that far
not that far off no i mean universities
are corrupt man yeah i mean we're [ __ ]
we're we're paying for monkeys to get
addicted to nicotine and crack and
cocaine at some level at universities
i mean that's really happening somebody
was like uh i uh will take monkeys and
give them
uh crack yes and then the guy was like
done stamps it signs over the grant
where does the grant come from the
government it's taxpayer funded all of
this is taxpayer funded you got rodents
smoking jewels
you've got uh what jewels like like like
vaping the douche flutes
wait wait rodents vaping vaping they
build special vaping chambers just for
mice and rats
and then they put literal jewels not
some
lab created off-brand i actually use
jewel brand can you just imagine being
like a researcher and you're like at a
party and you've got like your elbow
patches or whatever and there's like
you're this dude and this hot chicks
like so what do you do it's like
i give vapes to rats
like wait what yeah we have rats they
vape and she's like what
it's my job yeah we we have uh rats vape
like that's a really weird job we're
gonna walk away i really doubt there's a
city like i'm these guys like do they
lie about their jobs because i can't
imagine that impresses anybody like
they're at their high school reunion and
one guy's like you know i was the
captain of the high school football team
and i'm actually coaching a college you
know a small college in you know
missouri and it's like oh wow that's
actually pretty good one guy's like i'm
actually you know a senior vice
president of marketing firm wow and what
about you i give vapes to rats
so this is a classic case of um
the supply exceeding the demand or
whatever you know it's a little bit like
racism they're looking for it everywhere
they can't find it they have to make it
up if you give people a bunch of money
like literally unlimited money for
grants for this nonsense they're gonna
do stuff like see if rats know how to
vape and they'll
spend a bunch of money on it i don't
know why that one to me is just like i'm
just imagining south park doing a bit
about like a rat walking up and just
vaping because it's like it's the perfe
it's the perfect real world scenario
that's right for parity and it's pure
absurdity like
why are we doing that
people humans are vaping we can ask them
to come into university and we have them
answer questions and then do a physical
and we have data on people yeah and we
know that you know for years the
connection between cancer and smoking
cigarettes was obscured because the
tobacco companies were relying on animal
research and they're saying oh no it's
fine animals don't get sick from smoking
cigarettes and now we're doing this
making the same mistake over again
mistake or intentional yeah yeah we
gotta do more aspartame research too
donald rumsfeld favorite uh uh particle
but justin how much is this
how much of this is scientific research
how much of this is just cruelty
i mean i i'd argue that all it ranges
from the stupid to the sadistic right so
what's happening on monkey island i
think most people think is sick and
shouldn't be happening and then you have
uh last week with senator joni ernst for
thanksgiving we highlighted putting
turkeys on treadmills which was taxpayer
funded wait wait why
to see if domestic turkeys uh ran faster
than wild turkeys why do we need to know
do they why is that i don't remember it
now we got a very serious threat from
china
and if we're talking you know like land
ground combat and like a land war in
asia maybe we need to understand which
turkeys can carry the the weaponry into
the field either for combat or to bring
supplies hey maybe we get a turkey and
we put a first aid kit him and we let
him loose cybernetic and we're gonna
yeah cyber and we need to know which
turkey's gonna run for that's a long
game i like it i gotta miss i have no um
it may just be
let me put it this way there's probably
some turkey researcher who's sitting in
his office right now smoking a cigar
going like these idiots yes
and he's got like this top secret
document about like turkey research and
he's discovered something in turkey
muscle cells it's possible we just don't
understand something about turkeys on
treadmills but i think they need to
justify that like they need they need to
explain the goal of letting us
understand why a turkey runs faster than
another turkey because i gotta be honest
i got a 410 for turkey hunting and i
don't think it matters how fast the
turkey
the razor just completed and now we're
including a warning label on all 410
turkey load that says lead the target
slightly more if it's a wild turkey
compared to a domestic release turkey
that's what it's for yep yep like it's
paid for by gun companies for hunting
and that would be fine let them pay for
it let the poultry producers pay for it
to see who the fastest turkey is
um but should pack fares be faint
there's like the research is because
some dude has like underground turkey
races he's using government funding to
try and get an edge against us
he like flies to mexico and they're like
the turkeys are running
i can't imagine optical turkeys
justin did you see any of these papers
and and think hey this actually does
make sense i actually do want to know
about this this actually does benefit
humanity did you ever see
any of those particular studies yourself
um sure i've seen interesting questions
that have been asked um
but the question for me then comes back
to what is the cost to animals
uh which i'm concerned about and then
what is the cost of taxpayers is this
something we should we should be bearing
the burden of especially when we know
how inefficient it is and you know to go
back to your point about
uh
university research versus private
research i mean there's no incentive in
taxpayer-funded animal research
to innovate or to solve a problem
because the second you solve the problem
the money gets cut off so the actual the
incentive is to keep going and going and
going and not solve the problem and just
tinker until you retire that's how the
government works yeah and that's how big
pharma works and the prison industrial
complex and the military-industrial
complex and all the
larger
like they don't want to solve their
problems
because then
they they go out of business
yeah but that's why i think you know a
lot of this research is just a guy
sitting there being like i need a
proposal otherwise i'm broke so let me
just write up whatever i can and you
know get it approved and i mean to your
point that you made earlier i mean some
of it
you know you asked about the point of
some of this i mean some of it is just
tinkering at great expense to humanity
to like gain a function where you're
just trying to take a naturally
occurring virus and see if you can make
it more dangerous
it seems like a lot of the gain of
function stuff was literally just
we need something
because you you either you either can
you look you look at their official
explanation oh we did gain a function so
that in the event this virus emerged
we'd have a vaccine for we could
research it and it's like what are the
what's the likelihood of a virus like
that would emerge are you literally
going to make 50 billion different
viruses hoping that one of them that's
ridiculous
so then it just sounds like they're
either trying to weaponize it or they're
just bored and like i'll do whatever if
you give me a grant i guess
considering how fauci circumvented the
ban and like changed definition
definitions and tried to weasel his way
through this sounds more like they were
just trying to make weapons
it could be i mean eco health alliance
the intermediary the non-profit that was
taking the money and sending it to the
wuhan institute of horology it's a u.s
non-profit and actually
white coat waste was the group that we
exposed the link between the nih and the
wuhan institute of virology that that
money was passing through
um
they were also applying for money from
darpa for the from the dod to do gain
and function research and darpa denied
them saying this was too dangerous and
they hadn't taken proper precautions to
protect against
causing a pandemic so going to china
with very lacks safety protocols and the
chinese government looking over the the
shoulders of every scientist there is
definitely the smart reasonable thing to
do by of course mr science man and peter
dazak peter dazzak the bat lady i mean
when you delve into and do research into
them holy cow you find out a lot of
quote very interesting stuff that we
can't even get into on this show but
when you we really look into these
people
all the
warning signs are there on the wall i
mean i don't know how much research
you've done into those individuals as
well uh but but is there anything you
could say uh personally yourself from
your research about what they have been
up to what they have been involved in i
mean peter dashik has connections to the
chinese communist party going back
decades yup literally
he's a darling of theirs and which is
why they gave him access which is why
they let him in there which is why they
took his money and which is why they let
him come in and do gain of function
experiments that maybe could be
used for
whatever purposes that they could use
that a military or a rising power that
wants to challenge an existing power
might potentially use again we're
getting into the hypothetical here
we're speculating a little bit which we
need to talk about clearly but
with the information that we got i don't
think it's too far of a stretch to
exhibit some of those ideas or to
examine some of those ideas under a
critical point of view um i'm speaking
of course very uh well listen i think it
it would be naive to ignore the fact
that the wuhan institute of virology is
run by the communist party and that has
ties to the pla it doesn't mean that
what they were doing
was intended to be weaponized
necessarily but what they were doing was
incredibly dangerous
and
something that we wouldn't allow to be
done here yeah and that the chinese
communist party is bending over
backwards to cover up and
you know they've deleted the database
with their their virus database that
might lead us to whether they had a
virus that was like
the
coven 19. uh they deleted that in
september 2019. p the researchers at the
woohoon institute of virology got sick
with covet-like symptoms in november
2019.
the wife of a researcher at the woohon's
deuterology died apparently in december
2019
before all of that at the wuhan military
game there was apparently one of the
original super spreader events
so everything points to the fact that
this laboratory
is at the epicenter of the pandemic here
and there's literally no evidence that
this thing came out of nature naturally
other than the fact that other pandemics
have started that way
and there there have been
so the challenge is if you're a layman
you're reading the news their reports
they do say that the wet market natural
emergence theory makes the most sense
but i think i'll just talk to jon
stewart on colbert's show when he was
like you have the wuhan lab that does
experiments on sars viruses and then a
sars virus emerges just out just you
know across the street from the wuhan
lab and they say the the virus may have
originated you know a thousand miles
away or something it's like
jon stewart was a little more exuberant
in his presentation of this but the way
i describe it is it's like you find some
you know somebody laying on the ground
face down with you know a a bruise on
the back of their head and someone
standing over them holding a bat and
you're going to be like
there's no evidence to suggest this
person hit this other person so i don't
know it's just speculation guys the best
theories the guy just fell down
walking and he fell down and that's it
it's like i i mean i think it's fair to
speculate can we go look at the cameras
oh i'm sorry the cameras have all been
deleted and destroyed
about that and the guy who was leading
the investigation is actually friends
with the guy with the baseball bet
he's funded okay so we got a problem and
he's censoring all the information about
this entire incident and how it unfolded
huh interesting it reminds me of that
family guy joke
where the the bar burns down and then
the new owner gets all that insurance
money
and then uh i guess
the the main character's wives asked the
insurance guy they're like don't you
think it's a little weird
that he took out an insurance policy for
a fire and then had a fire the next day
and the insurance guy goes
no actually it happens all the time
don't you think it's a little weird
what's happening with the wuhan virus
the news reports the the the refusal to
do to release the data and the the
genome and stuff and it's just like are
we supposed to sit back and be like this
is normal
when it's very clearly not and they're
trying to stop us from investigating
what happened at the lab
at that point it's like look i am the
science yeah i understand if there's if
there's a virus sars covet virus
that emerges next to a lab that it
researches on and does chimeric you know
experimentation the creation of chimeric
sars viruses
it's the most ridiculous thing in the
world to be like
but it probably came across the street
from the wet market
and they've tested 80 000 animal samples
haven't found a single animal who had
saurus cov2
um
yet you have these viruses that are more
than 96 identical in the you know that
they were experimenting on and trying to
supercharge there and wuhan well now
we've got omicron
joe biden joe biden says
that if
we don't need i love this the headlines
are like joe biden says no lock down
necessary and i was like yeah that's
what they said in january whatever joe
biden was like we're not going to be
locking down doing mandates and then you
actually get to the middle of the story
where they bury the lead and he actually
said for now
if everyone gets vaccinated and wears
masks then they won't be necessary
and then there's this video of
university of michigan i guess football
game running under the field tens of
thousands of people and i'm like yo
people are not going to follow these
rules they're saying no to this
now they're saying daily beast is an
article that says we screwed up this is
really a three dose vaccine bill maher
already came out and said i took one for
the team i got my shots i got two i'm
not doing it again and i'm like the cdc
says the definition of fully vaccinated
will change to accommodate three shots
the daily beast is saying it's actually
a three-shot vaccine so now if you only
have two you're not fully vaccinated so
joe biden's gonna have no choice but to
be like look
come on man you know people didn't get
vaccinated so we gotta lock down to save
lives i think it's gonna be another
lockdown like it was last year i think
you're right joe biden has this habit of
doing this thing where he goes we will
all have unity and we will all get along
if you do exactly what i tell you to do
and i'm like how is that unity we're not
getting along for just doing what you
tell us to do this was what i was
talking about earlier with elitism he
thinks he knows exactly what's right for
everyone so just going to say this is
how it's going to be and if you don't do
as i say you're going to be locked down
again and you can go screw yourself
because i'm in charge which is not the
way the u.s has originally intended to
run this is not how it's supposed to be
but we've gradually stepped up what a
president can do and say
and it's
bad thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you